je trouve ça très très très cher ça fait
déjà quelques années que Max et mero
n'est pas rentré à la maison en France
pour le temps des fêtes c'est qu'il
voyage souvent l'étranger mais cette
année il voulait vraiment retrouver sa
famille et ses proches vraiment m'amuser
avec les copains voir ma grand-mère dans
le sud et puis quand j'ai vu les billets
j'ai fait oh la gueule les billets entre
1500 2000 euros juste pour l'aller sans
escale parce que un prix trop élevé
selon lui puisqu'il veut éviter les
trajets avec escale pour ne pas perdre
de temps dans les aéroports j'ai décidé
de laisser tomber de rester là pour les
fêtes même si c'est un peu plus triste
c'est vrai une décision difficile que du
prendre le Congo c'est pas la porte à
côté c'est en Afrique donc
il faut aussi prendre à l'avance mais
bon malheureusement parfois même quand
on essaye de s'y prendre à l'avance et
pas évident parce que les billets
coûtent cher elle estime que le prix de
l'aller-retour lui aurait coûté environ
1800 dollars une dépense qui ne pouvait
pas se permettre franchement du jamais
vu pratiquement moi ça fait plus de 40
ans que je suis dans ce métier et et
c'est vrai que bon pendant les fêtes
c'est plus élevé que d'habitude mais là
on arrive à des sommes vraiment au
dessus de 2000 dollars par exemple pour
aller en France
de l'agence de voyage planète France
déplore que ce sont les familles qui
sont les plus touchés généralement ce
sont des familles qui veulent rentrer
donc des adultes des enfants donc on se
retrouve avec trois quatre cinq billets
voir à acheter et ça ça fait énorme les
frais sont énormes lsime contre 25 et
30% de ses clients potentiels ont décidé
de ne pas voyager cette année c'est
triste
des porte-paroles de lignes aériennes
ont affirmé que les hausses de prix sont
notamment dûes à l'inflation et
dépendent du prix du carburant ils
ajoutent que la dynamique de l'offre que
la demande affecte également cette
tendance à la hausse ici Grégory Wilson
Radio-Canada Toronto